how would you describe the moods among
concert of MPS this conference well it's
interesting I must be on different
WhatsApp groups to everybody else
because I haven't had a singletory MP
tell me the things I'll Doom and Gloom
um I think I remember after the fiscal
statement was it five newspapers that
said this is the best statement the
conservative government has ever made
and I know a week's a long time in
politics but should we just calm down a
bit should we just see the growth plan
should we just make sure this is going
to happen and get behind the leader that
was undeniably elected in the summer I
mean you say to calm down but I do you
you must acknowledge though that you
know many of your colleagues we're
looking at those extraordinary whole
leads for labor they've been looking at
the extraordinary intervention that
happened by the bank of England to
effectively stop a run on Pension funds
you can see why they're a bit nervous
right I can except of course
um what is the real poll the real poll
are elections and what happened on
Thursday Two massive wins for the
conservatives up in Jake Berry's
constituency
um so people actually voted conservative
with with all this noise going on people
voted conservative that's what I hold on
to the important thing here is we've got
a growth plan it's going to take time
we're going to have more meat on the
bones on the 23rd of November my
daughter's birthday so I remember it
very very well really looking forward to
it and it's going to be a great day and
that's what we need to do we've got to
be subtle we've got to be tenacious
we've got to lay out what that growth
plan is about it's our duty to get our
economy going again it's our duty to
make sure that inflation is sorted out
it's our duty to make sure that
pensioners and other people have
absolutely got a future that they know
that they want to pass on to their
grandchildren how that's our job How
concerned are you by talk of spending
cuts because look we can all see the
economic picture here we can all see
that we're spending more on debt
interest repayments in the education but
it but it's been very clear from this
government that tax risers are not the
way they want to go how do you think
spending cuts are acceptable Jake Barris
is talking about during the fat or do
you think that many of your constituents
might be very worried about the idea to
cut to their Public Services well you
had Andy Street on just before me and
Andy and I are really old friends and I
thought his answer to you on this
question was really sensible any
business looks at what they've got any
business looks at
um not spending money on things that
they don't need to spend money on any
new prime minister will have new
priorities any new Chancellor will have
new priorities and it's absolutely right
that they look at the budget that
doesn't mean cuts it means where are we
going to spend more on that's the way we
should be looking at this according to
Liz trust this morning she didn't
consult with cabinet on scrapping the
45p a rate of additional tax on all of
those earning above 150 000 pounds she
said it was quasi-quarters decision
um how much concern is there among your
colleagues about that specific policy I
think what that actually tells you is
that she believes in departmental
government she deletes believes in a
cabinet where the secretaries have
stayed in their department they know the
budget they're going to get let's run it
properly let's run it like conservatives
let's have new priorities that's what we
need to do and that's exactly what you
know we are fed up aren't we with the um
seti that what did it used to be called
the the couch politics where everybody
just sits around and makes a decision
now it's not work like that if you're a
secretary of state you run a big
department you've got a perm secretary
you've got two Deputy berm secretaries
now I mean goodness me there's inflation
for you but didn't that that didn't used
to happen so why's that happened really
weird so take your orders from the PM
and and keep quiet no the Secretary of
State runs their Department with the
with the priorities that are
conservative priorities and that's
incredibly important
okay um well let's uh talk a little bit
about um what is happening on back
Ventures uh Jake Berry said that any
conservative MP who votes against the
budget so if you want to vote against
the 40-point abolishing the 45p rate
attacks that should be a confidence
issue you should lose the whip do you
agree I've been a whip twice
you know more than any of them perhaps
more than any and um yeah it's a vote of
confidence if it's a financial motion
for the government it's a it's a vote of
confidence and that's all there is to it
but we shouldn't get bent out of shape
over this
um there's a really interesting
interview with Laffer Laffer Curve so I
mean I don't want to do an economics
program on you here but this is where
you have every single government that
has ever reduced the top rate attacks in
the first two years have increased the
tax take that's what all this is about
it's increasing the tax take so that we
do have tax money to pay for the Public
Services you can't have public services
unless you have tax you can see though
your colleagues looking at those polls
feeling frankly that they don't agree
with the direction that the prime
minister is taking the country in
without an election and now they've been
told that they'll be effectively have
the whip suspended or be removed from
the whip if they make their unhappiness
known
um that's what the whips are for you go
and talk to your whip that's exactly
what the whips are for but I urge my
colleagues actually what happened last
Thursday we had elections we won
elections overwhelmingly the Laffer
Curve proves that if you reduce the tax
top rate you earn more income tax for
your government that means we can do
much more with public services and
that's what I want to do and that looks
after everybody that's the whole point
reducing the tax term to 19 beef for
everybody it's incredibly important but
if you reduce the 45 you get a bigger
tax take for the government and it means
we can support Public Services where we
need